hey everyone welcome to an announcement
video so in just a few hours i'm gonna
be playing my first
classical otb tournament
in a while it's uh the gibraltar battle
of sexes it's a really cool type of
format which i'll try and explain
there are
10 men
and 10 women
we can see the
rosters here this is chessresults.com
the way it works is i'll be playing one
classical game against each player
on the women's team
so 10 games total
and uh it's a team format so whichever
team scores the most points out of
the next uh what 10 rounds
will win a
hefty prize
it's a 100 000 pound prize fund and we
can see the
information here yeah and 75
goes to the winning team
so if i'm on the winning team i get 7
500 pounds which is i believe just over
10 thousand dollars if i'm on the losing
team it's
2500 pounds which is still a good
paycheck
but it should be a really kind of
exciting event exciting format
i'm really energized to come back to
classical chess
especially after so many months just
playing online and streaming
it'll be something new
so if we take a look at the player list
we can see a super diverse field almost
everyone is from a different country
uh we can just see the
the diversity of players i'm the only
player from the us i'm also the lowest
rated player
in the event at a measly feed a rating
of 23
56
so i actually prefer being
at the bottom of the rating list rather
than at the top
just because there's no pressure there's
no expectations
my goals for this tournament are just to
enjoy myself and have some interesting
and fun games hopefully learn a thing or
two
i'm trying not to be too results
oriented so
try not to worry about rating or
title or performance now there are
chances for grandmaster norm i should
note there are four
four or five gms on the women's team
and uh yeah i'll be an underdog in every
game so it's a good spot to be i'm i'm
excited
i
do get the question a decent amount
if i
want to become a grandmaster or when
will i become a grandmaster
if it's a goal of mine
and i will say that it's not a primary
goal i'm not actively trying to to get
the title but i am trying to
still enjoy chess to compete to improve
and yeah hopefully i can accomplish
those goals in this event now just some
background information
uh gibraltar is really really cool place
i got here just a few days ago
still recovering from jet lag now it is
a uk territory
but it's located just south of spain
very close to the northern tip of
morocco
and it's very scenic the the weather is
really nice it's uh it's like nice
autumn weather
um much nicer compared to the midwest
winter i'm used to this time of year
and there's a lot of nice places to walk
some nice hiking some wildlife and
here's just a few photos from uh my time
here so far
uh took a walk the other day found a
nice garden
with the sign er
also there is a logo of a king right
here so i feel like it was pretty
symbolic
for uh for my arrival
and we went to a nature conservation
center there's a lot of like wildlife
some monkeys
uh whatever this thing is called i think
this is a tamarin
and there is a bird
there are more monkeys
we hiked up to the
rock of gibraltar they have a lot of uh
a lot of wild monkeys they're actually
the only wild monkeys in europe
so it's pretty cool
and uh this was opening ceremony last
night this is uh the men's team
i don't believe everyone was in the
picture but most of us were
and this is uh the ladies team a lot of
big names here maria muzichuk
uh good friend irene sukendar
we have
sansaya who recently became a gm
pia kramling
also known as anna crowling's mother
is competing she's a the captain of the
female team
and the player who i'll be playing in
just a few hours
is marcel e framski from israel
as we see here
pairings for today
are already set
and uh i should probably wrap this up
soon because i should be preparing and
kind of reviewing how the pieces move
but the way it works is everyone on the
same team will have the same color
um i like how this says team sabino and
team pia the two captains of the event
but yeah so today all the men are black
all the women are white tomorrow we will
be switched
and uh i encourage everyone to follow
the games live uh the games will be
broadcast on all the major chess
platforms leachates chess.com
follow chess
uh probably some others too that i'm
forgetting
um i usually like to watch on leachates
um they do have the event already set up
to get to this page you just go to watch
broadcasts
and then it's right under tata steel the
games aren't set up for round one yet
but once a round gets going there will
be
uh live coverage
and also there will be live commentary
on the gibraltar chess youtube channel
it's called jib chess uh commentators
are lawrence trent
and irina palmaga
and i'm sure there's gonna be like post
game interviews they have a whole like
film production team here
so i'm really looking forward to it
it should be uh should be quite the
experience
i encourage people to follow the event
also engage on social media uh gibraltar
chess is very active on instagram and
twitter
and facebook i'll be posting on my own
social media platforms
and i am hoping to do game recap videos
of every single round
um now i don't want to go like too
insane and like burn myself out so
hopefully i can kind of keep the balance
of preparing for the games and playing
seriously but also doing content for you
guys
so i encourage people if you have
questions or comments leave them down
below
and i look forward to seeing you in the
first recap video